Hello. I am gonna be on the Daily Blast live tomorrow
talking about the Trad Wife life trend.
And so I have kind of been getting ready for that,
trying to make sure that my website has resources and stuff that it's
like, up to date.
There's also, you know,
people want to support and love that.
And I was getting an outfit today,
so I'm not gone.
I'm gonna do live again.
I'll go live tomorrow,
maybe when I get home after daily life,
like, I have to pick up my kids from school.
But I'm just really excited.
It's super fun to be able to, like, speak on behalf of us and, um,
I don't know. So I hope you guys watch,
I hope you guys get in the comments and, you know,
get in the conversation,
cause we know the dusty men have plenty to fucking say.